hello professor my question is which
element you lack best that's a very good
question and several people have asked
me and sometimes I give one answers some
at times another but I think the element
I really like best is sodium and the
reason is that the symbol for sodium n/a
is the same as the name that my mother
used when she was a little girl she
called herself na so every - and my
children called their grandmother na
so every time I see the symbol I get to
sort of warm feeling about my mother who
sadly died now and so I get a very warm
feeling about the elements hi professor
my question is this how did they decided
the names of elements and do you think
that the nazar they've put are really
appropriate you vote on it again this is
a very good question
and I asked professor Hoffman who works
in Darmstadt who has named elements how
he chose the names and what he said was
they also crowned the coffee-room
and they wrote the possible names on the
blackboard and then they had a vote on
it and it was really sad i sat in the
room where they chose the name of
meitnerium but they had cleaned the
blackboards so you couldn't see what the
names were and what is very nice is that
many years ago when people discovered
elements they named them after their own
country germanium after Germany francium
after France but now recently people
have started giving them names that are
more scientific that are not connected
to a particular country and the latest
element that Professor Hoffman named and
it had its christening its opening of
name day on the 12th of July element 112
is called copernicium of the Copernicus
the polish astronomer and I think this
too really honors a great scientist
irrespective of their country and this
is a very good movement
taking chemistry to a much more
international level which of the
explosions do you find most beautiful
and those exciting that's a very
interesting question nobody's ever asked
me that before and I think I think that
explosions there they're OK and they're
good for non-specialists but in the end
some of the things that I think are most
beautiful are things like the color
changes that you get in chemical
reactions and one of the the videos that
is cause most excitement of all the
videos we've shown with showing me
lighting a candle and I think that in
science and in chemistry it's often
they're quite small and subtle effects
that are more interesting explosions are
very good to get you started but then as
you get into chemistry you'll find that
some of the changes that are not so
violent are also interesting if you had
explosions in your body
you would not have grown to the size to
ask that question